Hey, Jennifer, how are you?
Hi, Evan.
I'm good, how are you?
And...
Man, how you doing?
I'm doing great, and it seems that we haven't spoken for a very long, long time. It somehow feels...
Kip.
It was a lot and then it was not a lot.
Correct.
And you seem very busy. What happened?
What? We are very busy. Yeah. Just the nature of the game, right? Ebbs and flows. We're up at a peak right now. Things are getting busy, but we're coming into summer and it always kind of like levels out in the summer. Knock, knock, knock. Because if it doesn't, we're in trouble. But no, we'll be all right.
Team.
Yeah.
Great. It's and it's good to be busy. That always helps.
Mhm.
I'd rather be busy than too slow.
Correct, correct. Let me share my screen and let's go over the deck. So we are going over the data for April. Agenda stays the same. And highlights, Ketan is doing good. Kam has increased her pace as well. I can see her ticket counts and the utilization, that's going good.
We'll discuss about that in future slides, but she's settling well in her role and she's excited to work with F12. That's great. She really loves her work. That's what she was saying. And she was maintaining her own data. I said, no need to do that. We can see it on BrightGauge and everything.
But.
Yeah, so she is being very proactive in that case. And she said, like, do you want to review? I said, no. See, I have the bride gauge. I can see. I do not need more details on that. So that's great. She is showing great dedicated alignment. So one thing is for sure, like her cab is generally not late. She reaches office before time.
Once there was a late issue, but yes, she called me proactively and informed. So yeah, she is all well settled. Now, over to you, Jennifer and Aaron. How do you feel Pam and Ketan are doing?
Um, I find if I, I'm gonna go first, unless you wanna go first? Alright.
I was going to say, I'll let you go first, Aaron. No, no, you go first.
Kip.
Yeah, so I think Keon is definitely doing well. He's really been what now, six, eight months. So he's really kind of come into the fold. He knows what he's doing. I can rely on him when I give him tickets, just kind of get it done or reach out when he needs help. So he's become a valuable member of the team. Pam is quickly catching up to him.
I think she is one of our leaders right now for CSATs. So she's getting a lot of positive review back from our customers, which is fantastic. I already am starting to challenge her a little bit more than I was in the beginning, giving her a bit of tougher stuff, and she's doing great at it. So I find them both ringing out very well right now.
Oh, great.
Great, great to hear that. Like, Bambi knew like she was earlier working with one of her partners and she was doing well over there as well. And that's why I thought like she would be the best fit for your team. Yeah. So all your apprehensions have been lost like she on her catching up.
She's catching up good.
Like she is, like she set the bar pretty high, to be honest. Like just how quickly she has immersed herself into the team and just more importantly, her approach to the team and her approach to, you know, rolling up her sleeves, being a team player. One of the things early on, I think it might have been week two for her, so
Oh, great. That's great to hear.
pretty early and we tried to shelter those first couple weeks. One of our seniors was quite busy and had a lot of tickets and we were on our huddle and she just looked at him and said, let me be your assistant for the day. Like, what can I help you with? And just proactively trying to take some of that work off of others.
Great, great, great to hear this, like, yeah.
Pre.
And even in my conversations, I get the same feeling when she talks to me and she says like, things are really going good. And I have kept Team Huddle, but she never joins that on daily basis. But why? She is busy on tickets and everything. But sometimes if she does not have tickets, she...
joins that. So that's really good to hear about Pam. I was more concerned when she initially joined because she was new to the account and everything. But yes, the way she has done, that's really great.
Okay, moving on next for the matrix utilization, that's going good. Pam, we know like it's 37%. It was initial half of the month, she was just learning the stuff and everything, so that's going good. Kian's utilization is at 88%, so that's good.
Ticket closures, yeah, for Ketan, it's 126 in Pam, just in the first 130, so that's good. Ketan, there were a couple of leaves that he had taken, so that's why his ticket count did not increase, but yes, overall good trend from him.
CSAT, Pam is 100% on 3 surveys and Kian 97% on 31 surveys. Yeah, so Kian got a DSAT. I would not count it on him because initially the ticket raised by user was, it left unattended and then the user raised another ticket.
And that's why he got the DSAT. He actioned that quickly. But yes, that's what I could see. Any points you want like to add, like where you see the ticket number was 3640461.
I'm just having a quick look here.
Apologies, April seems like it was so long ago.
Yeah, and the way March was going, it was going very slow.
April, it ran very fast and me also is running very fast, so...
It's 20th May already.
Yeah, yeah, the the CSAT for.
If.
For April, that and that user just only provides neutral or negative - that's just that's all we get from them.
Okay.
Okay. Yeah, but based on the investigation I did, I saw like these were the major issues. But okay for Ketan. Overall is, that's good. Yeah. Yeah, we know we want to set up the bar high for all the F12 customers, minimum 98%, so.
Yeah, you guys doing great.
Out of 50 servers you can only get one DSAT. So that's a pretty high bar that we want to sit and just want to make sure like Ketan is on that bar because he also loves getting CSATs and everything.
Yeah, one of the things that we've been working like across the team in general is just proactively asking for those positive reviews. So that's been our big push for May is to ask people to complete surveys and to take that extra second to, you know, remind people that our leadership looks at it, that I get to see what you say.
and really encourage our users to take that extra couple of minutes to do that. We've been seeing a pretty good increase through May for that.
Okay, and so in context to response rate, what do you actually see as a good response rate from you as an F12 standpoint? Not especially Kian or Pam, but overall as a team, what a good CSAT response rate would be?
look like when you would be satisfied like, okay, my team has achieved this.
Yeah, I don't know if I have one to be honest, because a lot of our clients are very different. A lot of them will not fill out a survey. Like you would have to absolutely like surprise them and you know, even then it might still be just a lower positive. And then we've got another client that is just coming on board now and all they do is give
Listener.
positive surveys. So I don't have a great idea of what response rate we're after as a team at the moment. That's one of the things on my list to figure out where we are benchmarked and then where we want to get to.
Okay.
Okay, so do you have a current benchmark at what you are sitting right now? Do you have that?
I think right now we're sitting around 23, 25% response rate. I would like to get that up. I'd love to be higher. I just don't know what's realistic with the base we have.
Well, I'll be very honest. One of my other customers who are from US, and I do not know whether this response rate changes between US and Canada, but yes, and their target is 10%.
Overall response rate. And you are already sitting at 25%. So one out of the four customers are giving you service. So that's really good. And I guess 25, 30% is really a good benchmark in terms of industry standards.
Yeah, I know there's a push, you know, across the board to really see that increase though and have the overall number of CSATs.
Oh, great. Just let me know if anything comes by so that we can also encourage our engineers to get more CSATs. But yes, I know there was one benchmark like getting at least 15 surveys in a month. So yeah, that's good in terms of getting those responses.
Okay.
Yeah, and I would say if you could just highlight the importance of, especially when, like, for the great calls where they know things have gone well, just ask, you know, ask the users to take that moment, remind them that everybody sees it, and it's really nice to have positive, positive words on paper.
Yep.
Yes.
Yep, that's correct. That's truly the thing I would agree with you. Okay, moving on to attendance, like overall things are going good. Pam is steady, but yes, she did take one unplanned leave and firstly when she was not well. And Khan, we know like he took three unplanned leaves like 6th, 20th and 21st.
6th, he was not well. 20th and 21st, we know that was a bereavement in his family and that's why he could not join. But overall, his leaves are going good. It was just an unfortunate month, I would say. Overall, he has been planning well and things are going really well in that direction.
And do they have, do you know if they have any summertime holidays booked or any thoughts on taking time off over the...
No, as far as I discussed with him, like he did not say any leaves or anything, and Pam, yeah, I would be honest, like she came from came back from long leaves. She had lost her father in the start of the year, and that's why she was on leave, so...
Ohh.
She, I spoke to her, she said like, I'm not planning any leaves for next one or two months until this sick leave comes in or anything, but I'm not planning any leaves. Giani has already taken few leaves in the start of the year. So I guess for next one or two months, he's not taking that, but I would say like.
Yeah.
If you have your team members already who have planned leaves, you can just let these guys know like these are the days when we cannot allow you leaves. You can plan after and before. So I guess they would be good in that. They won't be asking leaves. These guys are very accommodative.
Okay.
That they are.
Yeah, so it's usually, and in general, when the people take leaves, when they already have a family or something like that, they usually take, and I guess June or July, June basically May or June, but these two guys are...
single, they are not married and they do not have any kids. So yeah, I don't think they would be planning, but yes, I guess they would take leaves in October when the major festival comes. That's where they would take leaves, I guess, two or three days leave, not more than that.
Okay.
And it might be a possibility both of them apply for the same day because both would celebrate the festival. And at that time, usually, yeah.
Okay, yeah.
If we can accommodate that, we will, of course.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Yeah, so that's for that attendance and I will specifically check with them that if they are taking any leaves or not.
Yeah, and then just, you know, I don't think Keon's transportation issue has been much better, knock on, you know, fingers crossed, all of that, but just, you know, that is, you know, continues to be a concern that he's able to get in on time. I know we're on a pretty good stretch. I think he's had a couple of weeks now where he's made it on time.
Mm.
I.
Yeah, only one day, only one day and last I would say 30 days. So that's good. And that was genuine concern when we had some traffic concerns. But overall his.
Awesome.
Yeah, yeah, and stuff's gonna happen, right? Like people get sick, there's accidents, all that stuff.
Yeah.
It was just happening quite often.
But overall his cab issues have solved. We took a serious escalation to do all the levels and we got that solved. So we should not be seeing this, but fingers crossed.
Chan.
Moving on next, we'll continue to collaborate with Pam and ensure like she rams up quickly and she is able to meet the matrix how Kian is meeting. So I'm not going to say she would be at par in June, but yes, in July she would be at par with Kian. I definitely know that.
Yeah, I have no doubts or concerns whatsoever there.
Anything else you would like to add, Aaron and Jennifer?
Not at this front. I was just going to check about the credit that was going to be issued for Selena. I don't know if that ever got put through.
Well, in the billing, that might have already been done. We already shared that. So that should not be an issue.
Yeah.
Okay, perfect.
Perfect, I'll follow up with my finance team then.
Yeah, if anything comes, you can just send an email to Natalie because generally the billing is taken care by her. Natalie McKenzie, I'll just share the email. She is the associate director for...
Perfect.
customer success and she is also the account owner for FTool so you can go ahead and request if you find any discrepancies but overall I think that should be sorted.
The.
Awesome. And any word on how Selena's doing? I hope she's doing okay.
Yeah, so when we discussed like we released her from her duties from ITBD, we gave her an early release. Yeah, so she might be doing good.
Okay.
Hopefully, she's doing well.
Yeah, we gave a rest, so yeah, yeah, hope so.
Awesome. Anything else that you need from Aaron and I at all?
No, good. Just in case if you need anything or if you just see anything, any issues, just let me know on the chat and we can take it up from there.
But.
Awesome. Appreciate that. Thank you.
Great, thanks. Thanks for your time, Aaron and Jennifer.
It works.
Have a good afternoon. Price evening for you, evening.
You too, bye. It's 1146 in the night, so...
Bingo.
Awesome, thank you.
Thanks, have a great day. Bye.